Consciousness is not go is not in the
space-time straight jacket it's it's
it's free to have an infinite number of
completely different kinds of physics
with different kinds of laws and and for
us to be wedded to the SpaceTime one is
to limit our imagination about what
Consciousness can really do and what it
really is but it's just a question for
physics or or more broadly an empirical
question so I mean you've talked about
the Dynamics of Consciousness and the
Dynamics of physical reality for me
they're just same thing right it's just
that I I don't think that we
should a priori rule out the possibility
that there are many many more ways that
that Consciousness can give rise to
quote unquote physics than the one that
we happen to to know uh and as we start
to think out of that box we may be able
to find um clean empirical tests of that
hypothesis